the name of Malaya is super mechanical
functional assembly so you want to make
assemble assemble the structure with the
function after you gather you talk to
come home
pure purified then how do believe we've
got a pure compound so you have the use
a maker Emma and the mass spectroscopy
and chromatography to see the purity of
you come home that's called
identification the calibration there
after that step you get your pure
compound then you can start to study the
hostages the Pandi behavior and also the
band copies of your micro-cycles
so we use sugar to selectively highly
selectively attract the gold iron from
the mixture from the metal mixture out
from the water then we can get a bird
pure gold after very simple walk
hypothesis so our processes path has the
use of cyanide that's the major
advantage of our process firstly we
reuse the another software for ChemDraw
to to draw the structure we the
structure of formula formula of your
structure then chassis with the
molecular dynamic simulation then the
software will get optimized your
structure then you will see your
structure is possible or not so
simulation can make our water more
simple someone's opinion may contradict
yours what is my friend Alan it's all
about your perspective who are we in
what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sockin we are on site
at the beautiful West Lake University in
Hangzhou China we are now going to be
talking about supra molecular chemistry
we have dr. de Chun Lou joining us on
the show
hello thank you so much for coming on
our show really appreciate it super cool
it was so fun being in your lab -
getting a tour from you for those who
don't know - Chung's background he's an
assistant professor and principal
investigator at Westlake University
working on super molecular organic
functional assemblies sofa which will
unlock a new paradigm in organic
chemistry and you can find all of his
links in the bio below okay Josh on
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions we like asking our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world our thoughts I
think we are becoming very sick I mean
the our walls will be very precise we go
into detailed directions and we like for
example chemistry we are studying more
more deeply and we how to explain an
image think for example my research area
become very precise assembly I me just
when you start it deeply deeply and
deeply then you work more getting more
details
then other if either evil yeah I just
allow mmm
our mother will not be a uniform water
and more I think I will be personal
either or in you you unique I think for
everyone for example for the disease
therapy we have we can very accurately
to hear the disease without a suit other
parts of your body
yeah just a currency and yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is this is a good point it's
that we have newer and newer tools that
let us go to the deeper and deeper
depths of science and in your field
especially with chemistry yeah yeah
we're gonna be talking about that okay
who were you as a kid growing up and how
did you get interested in science and
chemistry actually I could interested in
science especially in chemistry started
from my primary school yeah because my
my primary school teacher shoulder
showed me where interests we came to
interaction Kim's reaction phenomenons
like the college shinji and the hydrogen
bond of those kind of chemical reactions
make me very excited so father the
atomic school I I have
I have had a Wellstone interested then I
pursue it maybe especially the through
high school and then to the languages
study then I start from my master's
degree I I went into the area of organic
chemistry and then after organic
chemistry study I investigated my PhD
study in the area of polymer chemistry
and then in my postdoc research area is
super mega chemistry so I I think all
these areas in my research can integrate
him to one so that's what I'm working on
now
so yes yeah I love the young kid that's
learning about collagen just color
changes and learning about just the most
fundamental chemistry things and gets
really excited by it and then ends up
pursuing the life in the field I I
really like that and this was organic
chemistry at London University first
yeah then a PhD in organic chemistry
from shanghai institute of organic
chemistry
yes and then you came to the United
States Northwestern yeah and did your
postdoc in super molecular chemistry and
Meccano stereochemistry so let's talk
about what that is because that's very
cutting edge super molecular chemistry
complex molecules held together by non
covalent bonds and this is usually large
groups of molecules that form sphere rod
or sheet like species
so why super molecular
what is this why's it so important
super green see is very important he won
the damn hole with our body our body
actually is a human with the same race
yeah maybe this is too big but for very
smaller for one sphere one sphere one
see actually is as severe like capsule
but that stupid assembly that a lot more
a lot Malik less then assembling the
double layer then from the the wall of
the sphere then in captured everything
DNA or everything inside of the capsule
then form a sphere so that's exactly a
super assembly so so for super gross
body we are going to study the basic
molecules how to assembly into
functional assemblies yeah so for
assembly into life that's the icing is
the the terminal tacit of wasabi and but
now maybe you know our very fundamental
study we we only studied the very simple
Lanka's to sing great assembly of mass
process so yeah we we start small simple
thing we are going to the complicated
one yeah all these assemblies rule non
queen interactions non quit the
reactions of example the parasitic
interaction and hydrogen bonding
interaction has rebound the interaction
is very
uniqua for maybe for protein for protein
you know the Prodi the hope roti the
anaemia opponent butter this linear
polymer can fold the and the coil into a
fleece or beta sheets structure then the
final structure we have become
functional so yeah that's that's what we
are going to do so that's why my the
type the name of Manabi is super
mechanical function no assembly so you
want to make assemble assemble the
structure with the function yeah that's
what we are going to do yeah I think
that's the tack they were all super
chemist yes yes so we want to understand
a molecule that is not just an
individual h2o molecule but we want to
make lots of molecules that are
connected to each other in an assembly
yeah that is functional in some way for
us yes and right now super molecular
chemists are interested in synthesizing
so first designing ones mm-hmm and then
synthesizing these super molecular
assemblies that have some sort of
functional purposes in our world across
different fields healthcare energy
agriculture it's unlimited right no
amount of fields it can be everywhere
simple molecular assemblies yes
super mega assembly something super
chemistry can be apply the merrier
mmm I think of one one area is for like
the for another truck delivery truck
delivery normally the some drugs are
hydrophobic but if you want to make the
you para in our bodies had a physical
environment so normally we use the
hydrophilic horse the molecular then the
which this molecular can bind it to the
hydro phobic truck
molecular then finally you were falling
a complex but the complex we have become
hydrophilic then you can put into your
body and get a good absorption yeah
that's one application size a lot of the
applications like maybe for the number
our the division for washing detergent
detergent detergent detergent detergent
yeah that that's actually the
self-assembly process we you using the
surfactant molecular the surfactant
Monica can form a capsule to to include
a lawyer or then move into water the you
worry you are in you dish is not what's
all about but after capsulation with the
surfactant event the oiler topper we had
to come me more soluble then you can
wash it away that's that's also
application of superman' chemistry so
super no circumstances whatever it just
uses the assembly behavior of best
moleculus or canning monetarists so
this one's very relatable is so yeah the
the little detergent yeah pods that I
put in the dishwasher or into the
laundry machine yeah that those have on
the outside that little the little thin
yeah that you know it doesn't break yeah
when you're into your hand but as soon
as it makes contact with the water yeah
for a long period of time and shake the
that's the super molecular assembly
breaks apart and it opens the detergent
yeah in the wash
yeah what's the thin sheet finish it
yeah male oh yeah top layer yeah that's
a super molecular assembly yes that's
exactly the to point assembly
interesting yeah and what do they do you
know what that's called that thin sheet
does it have a name we normally just
call the family structure is actually
quite a similar to the the wall of a
fair oh it's just the water cell yeah
yeah shafilea yeah double layer yeah the
head of burping Taylor inside the layer
and the hydrophilic head is the outside
of fear hydrophilic outside I drew for
peeping inside so that's in the what
area but I also you can use this on
reverse effect and that this process can
also be worse in all your environment
yes yes yes yes yes yes
interesting yeah because the hydrophobic
inside doesn't break because it's
connected to the more water and then the
hydrophilic is on the outside in contact
that we've been walking I'm talking with
the water and then break when it's ready
to contact and break yeah yeah yeah yeah
so double layer and you can switch you
can put hydrophobic on the outside
hydrophilic on the inside if you want
you can see yeah yeah for different
applications
yeah different the environment
you said one was you would put the
hydrophobic on the outside - if you had
oil or something oh yeah is that what
you said yeah yes yes interesting we're
in what when would you do that if you
had the oil on the outside all yeah our
Father think this one major application
is you know our chemical reaction for
the week or the disk and America faith
transfer Caprica mm-hmm
faith transfer so you have to layer one
oil layer when the excess layer then but
you have the transfers from reaching the
from the word faith to your oil phase so
you have to use this kind of who we
could have phase transfer catalyst yes
yes a phase transfer catalyst so I would
have to move something from one phase to
another phase yeah actually yeah the two
faiths are not for about cater the two
things are not soluble yeah if they move
one thing from one to the other
yeah yeah interesting and then the other
example you gave was the drug target
Johnson Aki yeah yes it's not a pity
whether you drug delivery yeah yeah so
you have to deliver a complex super
molecule to a very specific place inside
of body oh yes okay okay yeah and so if
you make a super molecule that can
identify in the body where it has to go
and then have it go mmm yes you can even
do that that yeah you can put the night
yeah that's equal to talkity talkity
really yeah yeah the targeted drug
delivery yeah
now let's talk about you know during
also the during the postdoc mm-hmm you
found it he co-founded a company called
cycling decks yeah
and this received an ACEF funding you
were isolating and purifying gold so
this also has a you have a process also
with what you're doing right now in the
lab with this purification process so
teach us about what exactly cycling Dex
is doing sacra Texas now is doing about
to scale up this process into practical
applications hopefully we can use this
into all over the world everywhere the
gold mines in all code mines because now
in now in now the nowadays the quadratic
code may be called the purification and
the code extraction called the recovery
people use the cyanide your very toxic
compound to extract the code from the
mind we cyanide cyanide tracked gold
from extract ODS so our advantage of the
process is we don't use cyanide we
baptize the use of cyanide we can use
the very environmental p9 compound we
call a secretary secretary actually the
sugar we can eat it yeah is a eight ball
so we use sugar to selectively highly
selectively extract the gold iron from
the mixture from the metal mixture out
from the water
we can get a whirlpool gold after very
simple
what couple process so our processing
type has the use of cyanide that's the
major advantage of our process because
now the Sanitation process he made a lot
you are mental destructive problem yeah
how do you get a sugar to bind it to
cold iron yeah how does the sugar the
sugar this this is also based on the
principle super-mega chemistry super mu
chemistry we use the non covalent bond
to form soup on very complex so the cold
iron with the for promet and coordinated
the co dine this kind of vocoder iron
can can be encapsulated into the cavity
of socket extreme secretary is the macro
micro cyclic to sugar then this micro
sacre-coeur sugar can find the cold iron
inside the cavity through hydrogen
bonding
yeah so you can get a very compact the
simple where complex and then this
conducts can precipitate out of from
water then you work at a pure gold yeah
that's what were actually i discovered
this this phenomenon and this process
for passive activity yeah so this is
yeah maybe I shall stay out of this is a
gift of God
yeah yeah yeah yeah Wow
yeah when you also study a field so
closely and so much also at the edge so
few people are doing
super molecular chemistry right now and
so of course the people that are gonna
be there doing it the first ones are
gonna find the lucky things yeah like
yeah gifts of God yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay and then this transition happened
in 2018 in September it's been a year
now to assistant professor in P I at
Westlake yeah and the super molecular
organic functional assemblies lab sofa
mmm sofa lab something out there yeah
and so let's start talking about this
you guys actually just published a paper
again yesterday and have had 54 of these
now high-profile scientific papers ten
patents let's talk about what's going on
in the lab and we'll start with the
fundamentals so what are these
fundamentals that you guys care about in
super molecular chemistry you I will
happen now the very fundamentals study
is one area is a sixth down to make
cyclic am huh because we are to
insuperable chemistry cyclic compound
normally we call the holster host
molecular sacrum are always can
encapsulate some co binding on c so make
the second compound then this can be
used to selectively a capsid some
Tuckerman across and make it maybe more
soluble or adjuster may be separated as
no others so this is the I think a very
fundamental idea is about the cyclic
compound yes yes we because it can in
caps
too late yes something it can yeah
because this the cyclical aspect to it
can house can encapsulate something in
it and usually what do you want to
encapsulate in it you gave us the
example of the gold early yeah yes okay
go with yes and then what else can you
house here or encapsulate here capsule
here actually you who defend them for
different guess termolecular we call the
the molecular encapsulate gas the
molecular so given the castle micro
can you different a wholesome reckless
so names again yes
desta gue SD Java yes is on the inside
the exam inside the coffin yeah yeah
yeah and how the house Hoffman the whole
host hot okay cool
so the host is here the one that's
encapsulating yeah yeah host yeah this
is the guest that comes in yes yeah ha
forget for chemistry we also call host
guest chemistry yeah this is the parent
[Music]
parent name with Suppan River chemistry
some time host yes yeah cool before
cyclical so important Oh quickly good
yeah
cyclic a well important him yeah so okay
who else can be the guest a lot lot a
lot like I I say that the the calculated
a code the ion easy the one that's
totally hydrophilic one but a lot of
hydrophobic molecules like as I said
there may be some hydrophobic attract
monetarists and also
sometimes just some petrochemicals the
command a no different toluene xylenes
than a mixture we can use the micro
cyclic compound because of different
isomers has different a banty
Association constant so you can get a
very good a separation and only for
separation is a very important for
chemical engineering so especially for a
patron you ate nearly Athena yeah so
we'll make rather a lotta just chemicals
you have the purest family you you get a
mixture for example today we showed in
the lab the the chromatography you have
to use this and see if there column to
purify your compound you mixture you get
a pure compound but as I said we can
also use the macro cycle microcycle
compound to purify your you mixture
together the Pacifica one yes okay go
get will get here in a little bit on the
purification let's stay with the next
step so we have this fundamental of the
having us a cyclical and cyclic AF host
hasta yeah cyclical host and then you
want to design the host yes okay yeah so
you in order and this is hard because
the host that you're designing is
sometimes it's not found in nature
yeah so you have to make make yes
synthesize you you're gonna synthesize
something that's not found in nature
okay so then you have to design
what this cyclical molecule should look
like
yet the details dr. human detailed
structure of yeah of the super molecule
yeah microcycle yeah yeah okay
and so then teach us about the the
design because you have to use software
chemistry software you have to use
simulations yeah use chem 3d is one of
them and Spartan there's another one so
how does your lab use the software to
design the molecule and have the
simulation so you know that it's gonna
be good good host
yeah firstly we we use the another
software called ChemDraw to to draw the
structure we the structure of faulkner
formula of your structure then just say
with the molecular dynamics simulation
then the software will get optimized
your structure then you will see your
structure is possible or not if it is
the possible structure then you are
going to make it but if is not is not
possible is a very uncommon structure
well strange a one then you will think
about maybe I have to redesign or
improve the structure or something that
yeah so simulation can make our work
more simple but yeah you can add as well
just a finger with your hopper end and
make it the maybe in the end then you
get a useless structure so that's
possible so we have to make a true make
sure we don't waste our time yeah so
you're making sure that the the host is
gonna be able to
possible Department of functional and
functional yeah maybe you may you'd
design the macro cycle but finally the
structure is not is not a micro security
is a test poverty class structure then
you do need to see inside yes yes
yeah that's why you've run the scanner
simulations they make sure that the
molecule that you're designing is going
to be functional yeah I think nowadays
for the simulation where is help from
the important therefore our Fadi yeah
one more important yeah and maybe even
going for the AI can help us too oh you
just give me a water sidewalk and the
water moieties we are going to use for
to make the structure then the AI can
help you to divine yeah yeah yeah I
think that's possible
oh yeah we can use the computational
capacity in the creative capacity to run
a lot of different simulations
yeah maybe millions of designs of what
could it be an optimal host yeah yeah
yeah
interesting hmm I love how applicable
simulations are to scientific
advancement this is very cool okay so
then let's say you get the really good
molecular design very functional mm-hmm
okay so now is the organic synthesis yes
okay so you want to achieve a target
molecule down the line this molecular
design what you made for the host you
want to achieve it down the line yeah
but you need to add first these non
target molecules solvents reagents and
then you need to go through this organic
synthesis process so teach us about
what's going on
the synthesis process yeah you see says
normally for the tequila come how we we
are we can synthesize through one step
or multi steps so for three normally you
run carry out organic reaction organic
then after the reaction you normally
firstly remove the song by rotary
braided then use the chromatography to
purify you compound then cut you get the
next step car start material then you
use this compound to do the next step
reaction then again again to go to the
Tucker come home after you gather you
talk the come home pure purified then
how do how do how do believe you get a
pure compound so you have to use a
nectar Emma and the mass spectroscopy
and chromatography to see the purity of
you come home
that's called identification the
congratulation then after that step you
get your pure compound then you can
start to study the host gets the pandey
behavior and also the band properties of
your micro-cycles
so yeah whoa okay so this first part of
the organic synthesis you have to find
the right non target molecules to add
two solvents and reagents to try and
make this final targeted yes molecule
that you design that's how do you even
how do you know what reagents solvents
and non target molecule
how do you know that if you combine
these things together it's gonna make
this really good host that you designed
so we have a process called Rachel's in
situ analysis you get in Tucker come
home then based on the pack the comma
structure you can use the Rachel's in
Sector analysis - Rachel analysis the
all the next paper yeah so retro
synthetical and now it's a manic 50s Wow
is that RSA do you say that RSA
retrosynthetic analysis not yeah and you
can call IFA yeah this RSA
retrosynthetic analysis you can take
what is the molecular design the final
target one yeah and it will this
retrosynthetic analysis will say why
don't you try these molecules these
reagents and this salt yeah Wow
yeah step by step in the Gua go back to
the Stata material Wow
yeah how does RSA work or does it guess
what this I say I think I lost in most
cases based on the literature the
literature yeah yeah yeah you know your
final structure yeah so you have the you
have some because of the totally new
totally brand-new compound but you have
some similar functional groups or
moieties
you can find the literature how the
system this kind of moieties then
integrated together maybe yeah yeah Wow
but sometimes you need to try so so does
RSA have a catalog is there good like a
dictionary or a library or you know the
big catalog so that
I can say that okay maybe this molecular
design could have a different way yeah
different ways but it could be like
maybe like a library or catalog where
it's like okay this molecular design is
kind of similar to this other one yeah
they're gonna have kind of similar RSA's
yes these are very different so they're
gonna have very different artists yeah
this is a big catalog of final molecular
designs and how to possibly get to them
yes you come back to me and then every
time you have a new simulation of
molecular design you you you go through
the process of the RSA and then you do
the organic synthesis with what the RSA
said and then if it's successful but
mostly successful you give maybe you can
do the the training the Machine training
and say that was a good RSA
recommendation yes actually
some chemists are doing this process by
AI yeah yeah that's the power of way I
think yeah maybe you can
after the the machine under law enough
processes in reactions so then the
machine can give you a very good way to
synthesize a very short way or very
simple way are very high fish in there a
way to society with harmonica yes yeah
yes Wow
so there's there's some organic chemists
ones that are doing the super molecular
assembly some are figuring out how to
train the Machine and say this RSA was
bad this RSA was medium this was good
for this specific molecular design that
we're looking for so they constantly
give it a new molecular design and see
what it gives for an RSA do the organic
synthesis and see if it was good
bad where it was and then get in the
Train the machine just rain the
algorithms to give better and better our
essays yes yeah so you have higher
higher success rate every time you do
your synthesis yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Wow Wow
again RSA retro-synthetic Oh management
analysis retrosynthetic analysis yeah
Wow yeah
okay so then okay so now you've figured
out what mauled the RSA told you what
molecule solvents and reagents to put in
and then you now now what happens do you
you like I saw in the lab you have a
process of like the machine is kind of
maybe maybe doing the the circular
motion of the the synthesis so so how do
you know if you have to shape you have
to move it like this what temperature it
has to be at it has to be cold it has to
be really hot because you have the very
cold machines yeah yeah yeah how do you
know what temperature and what motion
and for how long for for one specific of
reactions normally we firstly we go into
the way to read the literature to find
the similar compound how the sister that
one we we use firstly we use the similar
conditions to since I've our new
compound yeah so firstly we we look into
the literature to find the sound
references then follow the references to
maybe to improve it or something like
that to to reach our compound yeah okay
so you if you have a molecular design
that is completely new
yeah you look for something similar in
the literature yeah and then if you
don't find something similar then it's
kind of a guess a close guess as close
as you can get yeah totally planned no
no no and in each literature reported
then you you can try and yeah you can
develop a new way a totally new way
since either that or maybe you have to
doubt your divine has some problems no
because why aren't people going towards
that design oh yeah yeah okay but you
could have some good idea yeah yeah
maybe you just make a great amount of
that yeah yeah okay so okay so you look
for what if you usually when you make
the molecular design you find some
literature that says okay this amount of
heat or cold over this amount of time
and maybe spinning or yeah okay so
you'll find the theme in a condition
similar conditions okay yeah and this
takes can sometimes be several days
yeah the synthesis to happen yeah
sometimes like overnight
oh one week oh maybe few hours yeah Wow
anywhere from a few hours to a week or
more eunbi okay and then okay so then
once the once that that that
synthesizing process is done then you
have the you have your your target
molecule molecular design is in this mix
makes - yeah and you want to purify yeah
it out of the mix yes okay and then this
is where you are teaching us about a
rotary evaporation so that's the first
one so you go and you have the mix do a
process of moving the solution of
Junction yeah it's real mixture yes then
first three you
after actually after reaction you get
the solution mixture then we normally we
have we have some workable process work
up a process to to remove sound like a
salt the salt or something that to wash
your organic face then to dry then then
correct your fair trade that's the the
solution of your mixture but you remove
the sound in mechanical sort or others
water soluble impurity or something that
this is the first purification then
after you connected with your solution
of a mixture then you could you wrote
evaporator to remove the solvent remove
the solvent you work at the residue
that's a solid normally normally maybe
also oil depend on the red point of your
calm huh yeah then you gather your your
solvent is literally separating ya from
the mixture yeah from mixture yeah
through this rotary evaporator then
you're just spinning the rotary
evaporators yeah to make the reparation
fast evaporation and you have a little
like water yeah what yeah what I can
keep it yeah yeah solvent gets
evaporated get separated yeah and you're
left of the mixer K the mixer so now the
mixture the mixture without a solvent
then you can use the chromatography to
purify your yeah purify together what
what they come what he want
yeah yes yes yeah now what inside the
chromatographer this is like the last
step of the purification yeah in the
chromatographer you were teaching me
before we started it's like a race yeah
threats yeah and so you you're
your final target molecular design is
going to is it gonna come first or is it
gonna just come at some point different
than the thumb point of view from some
point if that's okay later or second
third or whenever yes yes okay yes does
that make make the distance between two
Pub a big enough yes so you you have
enough time to connect then yeah yeah
get a enough purity yeah
what does the chromatographer do to the
mix to make it so that the two or three
or however many are left so that they
separate yeah this is a kind of war we
call the absorption desorption process
so if the your combo has strong panty to
the to the column and so no the job
you're talking to come home you're wrong
we're slow because there's bandido is
strong but evil another comma appending
we're weak so fast
yeah it's okay you can cool yeah okay so
you can separate okay okay and then now
you have your final target molecules you
have it and now you need to do
identification yeah so this part you use
you need to make sure it's the correct
compound yeah you want to what you
designed in the software with a
molecular design and we're now going to
do nuclear magnetic resonance NMR and
mass spectroscopy yes to basically see
if if what you see in the identification
is what you designed in the sauce yeah
to see them that the the the calm how
you gotta have the correct structure yes
yes if it has the exact structure you
want it to be exact
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and then the
next one is the electron microscopy hmm
and the atomic force microscopy AFM hmm
and this is B this is because you're
starting to study the super molecular
assembly yeah okay so once you identify
make sure it's the correct compound then
you need to go a little bit deeper yeah
great people to study the assembly
behavior of your compound maybe for
example or for my gold extracted coded
recovery work discovery
I used the SEM to discover the
Assemblies the the Assemblies of the
stock texture with Kota is actually the
highest back to racial nanowire you can
clearly see with the SEM scanning
electron microscopy yeah so that's after
you make a you attack the compound then
you either talk to come home to do
assembly yeah okay so okay you see that
the assembly is what you wanted it to be
in the molecular design okay so it's now
what you want it to be now you need to
figure out because you were teaching me
about this that the yields can be a
little low yes that mole yields yeah for
the Mac macro cyclic compound normally
the years is quite no so sometimes we
have to improve
Paul Synthetica process yes - good -
though you can say yeah
yes yeah there's no machines the size of
this building uh-huh yeah for for doing
the the organic synthesis for one whole
day imagine the the building was either
super cold or super hot and it was being
moved around you know because then you
could maybe you could do you know big
bioreactors full of organic yeah a
mystery yeah
processes yeah yeah yeah yeah in my
record actually now people are doing
where they I think they can do very
complicated the organic synthesis but
then you also need the bioreactor sized
the rotary evaporation the bioreactor
sized chromatography oh yeah bioreactor
size for every because if you want to do
an identification to make sure it's
incorrect for every single one of those
and so you'd have to find a way to batch
yeah the whole thing for the proper
molecular assembly to make sure that it
was all right or and to get rid of the
ones that were wrong
yeah it would be wow that would yeah
yeah by the do you see that where the
future is going in the big bioreactor
direction for for super molecular
chemistry for these organic synthesis
yeah I think the future yes that's yeah
as what we are doing now the lab the lab
experiment is totally different from the
factory process so yeah learn the baby
steps still yeah more most of these days
you can do in the lab space butter 2 to
letter to factory or
you couldn't in every area that we
impossible maybe totally too expensive
was nothing less for now and this may
change down the line maybe yes so then
you know okay so if this turns out to be
you know slightly wrong in some way if
it was you know you look and it's the
wrong super molecular assembly or if
it's the slightly wrong compound that
came out then you need to go and change
the variables in the organic synthesis
process yeah and try again
yeah yeah and then you keep trying and
trying and trying until you get the
right okay and then once you get the
right one then you also want to test the
mechanical properties of what you got so
if you wanted to make a good host you
want to make sure that it can happen
yeah if that it could have the guest
yeah
and that it can do what you want it to
do yeah okay yeah yeah so mechanic
properties one possible one possibility
yes so normally we firstly may we made
the made the target macro cycle then we
use some spectroscopy to study the panty
constant to different guests if you see
a seasonal cycle panty to a pen pen to
pencil to the character one one specific
as well show me then maybe you can
separate this gas America specifically
with this macro cycle so that's what we
call a purification you can purify the
recorder we can use a circuit Xtreme to
purify the code out yeah that's one
major
I will super-move attempt I think yeah
hmm okay so if you get to this point
where you're starting to increase the
yields and you're starting to make sure
that the mechanical properties are being
of great quality it's actually working
then let's talk about where exactly then
this could be also deployed because we
know you mentioned some of the things at
the beginning and now that we have a
good idea of the actual you know process
of getting it there I want you to teach
us about the topological structure
design so you were explaining to me that
you can have molecules that instead of
having a covalent bond that holds them
together you can have a mechanic's bond
that holds them together like two rings
yeah like this yeah
and this is so interesting because we
don't know if this is found in nature
hmm yeah we don't know yet we don't know
yet if it's found so this could be
totally synthesized by us and it could
be very powerful a mechanical bond yeah
mechanic phone yes actually this people
can all already see that this very
simple you need to ring mechanically
knock together
yeah but yes this is a very basic
mechanical bounty unit yeah so we are
going to design much more complicated
topological polymer honking nose like a
you make
Nick nice yes Nick nice the Monica
necklace monocle necklace is a multiple
ring intoxicated to make a bigger ring
yeah yeah okay yeah and why would you
make that why because this this candle
when we can upon has very unique
properties because this ring and we do
not have covalent bond the bond together
so p32 rings and don't have any strain
energy this is totally free delete all
the free movies free movie yeah so you
can just this kind of you like you see
the the necklace is where we smoothly
change the shape and the kind of flow
you mean yeah like a lake creative role
yeah because once if you you know you
hold the string of chains and then if
you just you know drop it down it just
good yeah he just falls perfectly into
the little while
actually the like the sug the the the
pastor then should yeah
then yeah yeah make the talk later maybe
talk the world is some kind of liquid
yeah yeah yeah yeah para either polymer
either yeah solid right because that has
a very unique for soluble material where
do you think that can be used the
mechanical not in a necklace shape can
now I think we're even also in a lattice
it can be made it a ladder there's a lot
of booty to delight who do 3d or 3d yeah
or 3d where don't think those can be
used the this can be used I think a for
example the shape for because this
bounded by
mechanic pong really then don't have any
string energy so sometimes if you use
the ion tube and it to be teetering then
you will make the structure stronger
because the ring the two reconnected
together then the structure is very
strong but after you remove this ion
then the the hole a 3d structure we have
become class yeah so the shape can
change a the mechanic properties can
change
can you angular the capacity capacity
also can change yeah so this could be
important for like nanotechnology yeah
sure yeah
if I can very easily go from 3d lattice
yeah and then - yeah tiny little
difficult at the opposite yeah Wow
that's can it go back from the tiny yeah
Tesla no we called a shape shape a
memory material shape memory material
yeah yeah chip memory but how do you
you said remove the ion yeah for the
Adamo that we can you the ion to
moderator the property change yeah yeah
yes but I can reintroduce the ion yeah
and then is how would it just go shape
memory that expand the earth yeah how do
i reintroduce the ion what would I have
to do if I had an object that could go
back and forth how would I reintroduce
the ion or take it away if integrity the
way normally you can use a extractor to
to take the or just if file can be
oxides or or neutral just use the
sensitive to if with the band is
stronger then you can extract the ion
out then the structure will collapse or
just a new tries the structure we
crap then you can put again and yeah
this is the one kind of esteem rate but
we can also you they like a pH value
change oh yeah or even just the light
you delight because the some moleculus
can change the shape can change can
change the confirmation just the in one
conformation maybe to recombine the very
strongly then another dimension
confirmation the ring can rotate the
very for freely so through optical
stimulation yes too light
yes yeah that's quite the interest yet
Wow although is impossible
yeah cuz with with when we talk about it
for Neuroscience we say up to genetics
you know for modulating uh-huh neurology
maybe there's an opto super molecular
chemistry yeah yeah yeah in follow we
call may be integral not up to photo
super mega chemistry boto super
molecular chemistry supernova for the
chemistry me feel super molecular photo
chemistry yeah yeah interesting yeah Wow
and also the nanotech potentially
sciatic - yes yes so - polymer chemistry
is either interdisciplinary chemistry
super molecular nanotech light
multidisciplinary chemistry it is very
multidisciplinary chemists yeah yeah
yeah yeah it is it's so
multidisciplinary Wow Wow
I opted of super molecular
nanotechnology
with a la yeah it's so funny adding the
words to it
uh-huh okay and I'm kind of envisioning
a little bit like me being able to do
something like down the line being able
to have really strong devices that can
collapse down hmm
fit in my pocket and then for me to be
able to take them back out and to bring
them up in back into their lattice yeah
shape yeah and then to access what I
need to do with it yeah that's that's
the pathway yes yeah actually this is a
kind of see the wall application of this
kind of Mercury's just for absorption
because when you turn you to the wonders
of Supremacy then the structure can be
cracked there but if you don't absorb it
as I expand then you can absorb a lot
and we get them all inside then if you
want to squeeze the gas out then just
injure a little structure time and all
absorbs where should the host can be
expanded and hold the guest and then
when you're ready to release the
guarantee forget that the collapse and
the guest yeah yeah yeah yeah Wow
interesting
yeah so that could be really good for
like drug delivery targeted drug
delivery yeah yes yeah I'm very very you
know slightly bigger without the with it
and then
actually the steam irresponsible
materials steamer responses stimuli
responsive materials yeah so to light or
to other stimuli
yeah respond yes yeah interesting Wow
okay okay and then you gave also you
telling me before we started this other
example which was the you like the
potential of the double helix super
molecule yeah I think that's really
interesting to you gave the example of
the rings but could it also be if it was
the if it was the the the the double
helix intertwined all the way also as a
lattice or as the yeah yeah yeah and
then those have different properties
they have different applications because
they'll have different strengths yeah
yes been different the mechanical
properties yes Pradesh yeah yeah so yeah
so different approach structure I think
can make very unique structures or even
with very unique properties and the
movements or something that yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean movements to then you
also you know we're talking about
several times about but these are all
things that we have not found in nature
everything that you're talking about was
super molecular chemistry is designing
things synthetically organically that is
not found in nature at least not that we
know yes yeah and so then we can do very
novel unique things with health or
agriculture or technology or any sort of
advancement that we want to make because
we can synthesize it we can simulate it
and synthesize it
we can bring it into our world that
really big scales like bioreactors and
as this can be very impactful you were
also giving me other examples too before
we started porphyrin conferring ethical
friend was one of the examples yes ok
porphyrin that helps us carry oxygen
like it's like hemoglobin yeah yes yeah
it's like hemoglobin yeah ok
yeah and then so that can be something
that helps us with our our health and
then other ones are like photovoltaics
photovoltaics here is another one yeah
although photosynthesis also
photosynthesis
yeah implant yeah yes yeah so we can
maybe have you know the like some of our
buildings and and more of our things we
can have more of our things potentially
get energy from light yeah guarantee so
that that's why a photovoltaic is you
reason they have to wear put a lot yeah
yeah so so super molecular chemistry
could make photovoltaics more efficient
yeah makes them better at receiving
energy from the Sun yeah I think it's
possible yes yeah yeah it's possible to
make it we're uh we're all currently the
yeah yeah make the the time on Icarus
where organize it in the device I think
is one way to enhance the efficiency
yeah yeah so you can highly efficiently
connected the energy from light
wanted to electricity yeah yeah so Wow
there's so many interesting applications
and so interesting also learning about
how it's actually done the steps of
super molecular chemistry about how it's
done
it's really good to learn about the
steps from you mm-hmm all right let's
ask about the meaning of life what do
you think this big human experience is
about wasn't the purpose the the meaning
of life I think of the meaning of knife
with this question is a very big whether
my questions and I answered the knife we
will you for giving mmm not taking I
think yeah yeah just give me like yeah I
think a we already I got a lot of song
nature so we just have to kill yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah meaning of knife like we've
gotten a lot from nature so yeah yeah
yeah
how come you inspire more people around
the world to work together I think
people have to love each other then they
think about the other people's more and
like a president the king disabled ask
what you can do for the country and
don't ask what the culture can do for
you I think that will make people work
together and yeah think about other
people turn the tuna be selfish having a
yeah
walk walk together I think
very good way because I think one one
person how would have huge any meat I
think even even you are huge a you have
greatest scientists I think the the
limit is obvious there yeah even are are
you I think a no people should think
since therefore I is much to be walk
ready
where's the person I think people should
be e yeah I will no cancer for very
clear yeah yeah I really like that quote
a lot about what can you do for your
world what can you do for our world not
what can the world do for you I like
that a lot that's a really good one and
know yourself and an increased
collaboration around the world
yeah yeah what about a skill that young
people can know going into the
exponential technology age uh-huh for
young people I think we should work hard
and maybe you are not smart enough but
you can just work hard and you will
always keep with an Ernie attitude
altitude yeah
always will keep money yeah like people
or if you are poor but I think if you
always work hard you can make your
region in mmm buried or with you either
way you can give it one thing yeah just
a work heart and many I think no no
other straight war
a way to bypass on this I think you
always have to know like a sound I got a
no pain no gain
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's good what do
you think your industry super molecular
chemistry what do you think it's gonna
look like in 50 or a hundred years what
would be the ideal tool the best
possible tool for your industry in 50 or
a hundred years what will that look like
that tool you mean that's the tour yeah
okay in the spirit and you 50 or 100
years I'd see the tour almost no people
walk there yeah all machines we can do
everything the people just in enjoying
to but I think yeah I in you know I
think in next few years maybe become
sweetened to talking being yeah yeah I
think you sound people using a I'm not
correctly they will make the AVO machine
and the fight of it will human being
yeah yeah this is very important we were
talking about the power of all of the
the permutation now capability for
creativity and even something like super
molecular chemistry you wouldn't we
wouldn't have thought that we could
simulate out billions of potential
molecular designs and then go through
the synthesis process and see if it
comes out well and make it in bio
reactors could it be that a hundred
years
the line that super intelligence can do
all of that
yeah but also if we get these powers
yeah can we be smart enough to not hurt
ourselves yeah yeah Internet each other
yeah it's not enough kindly enough I
think loving enough yeah yeah not enough
yeah this leads me into the next
question what do you think is the role
of love in our world I think the most
important role in our life we our what
people should love each other always
even your enemy is a lovely lovely yeah
yeah don't hate anyone just loving and
the understanding and the helper then to
love you yeah yeah yeah yeah speaking so
much of simulations now do you think
this reality is a simulation yeah this
reality this I and I don't think this is
a simulation this is real yeah yeah what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world most beautiful thing most
beautiful most beautiful thing I think
[Music]
harmony society maybe yeah why did you
say that because I want to see people
very nice and every second
very smooth yeah you just look area no
kimi no and a bad thing for Hammond I
think all that most beautiful thing yeah
a harmonious society yeah yeah yeah sure
thank you so much for this episode thank
you hey you want your walk coming on our
show teaching us about your work no
really my pleasure
yeah thank you thank you for watching
today thank you everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking have more conversations with
your friends families co-workers people
online about super molecular chemistry
about the way that we can do things like
make new fundamental advancements in
this field to design new molecules that
aren't found in nature to do these
processes of organic synthesis to purify
and to for us to be able to design new
topological structures as well have more
conversations about that also check out
the links in the bio below did you
Chung's lab also to his papers to his
twitter to his linkedin to his work and
reach out to collaborate as well also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the organizations the leaders around the
world that you believe in in your
community support them and support us
simulation so we can continue doing cool
things like coming on site to Westlake
University and interviewing some of the
smartest people here support us and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace
yeah yeah I got real awesome I mind so
blown about super molecular chemistry
and just how hard it is to you know that
was so interesting I didn't ask you
about that before we started
retro-synthetic oh and that if analysis
how cool is that - Wow
[Music]
you